you are watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video in
previous videos we've looked at how
Tesla is shaking up the automotive
industry but recently they're taking
things a whole level further as many of
you would have heard Tesla has released
a software update for their late 2014
Model S and Model X series cars I know
it doesn't sound like much of a big deal
but it's actually starting to turn into
one the thing that's interesting and the
main focus of this video is that the car
actually learns how to drive pretty much
a breakthrough in the automotive
industry or get to the details of that
breakthrough in a second but to get
started let's see the system in action
that's pretty impressive would you have
reacted in time let's just take another
look at that at those speeds if the
driver had at all been distracted the
result could have been very different so
what does this new update include the
car can do almost anything so we're able
to obviously do lane-keeping on freeways
to automatic cruise control active
emergency braking
it'll-it'll self-park so you'll be
automatic parallel parking automatically
going to a garage you'll get home and
actually be able to just step out of the
car and have it park itself in your
garage
including it'll it'll open the door and
it'll go in and park itself going a step
further you you'll be able to summon the
car if you're a private property because
you have to be in private property booth
you can actually sum the Cardinal the
car will come to wherever you are and
it'll it'll it'll use the ultrasonic
sense is kind of like a insect antennae
slowly make its way to you and then it
stopped and be ready to go it can
actually go even a step beyond that
which is if you have if you have your
calendar turned on it'll it'll meet you
there
okay so how does the car land it learns
from humans of course this is the real
breakthrough in a recent press
conference must refer to each model s
owner as an expert trainer that feeds a
collective AI network by simply just
driving the vehicle on autopilot in
other words each Tesla driver trains
their car when they drive an autopilot
mode by doing this the reinforce wanted
driving behavior from the car and
discourage unwanted driving behavior but
the interesting thing is all Tesla's are
part of a fleet so when one car learns
it teaches that to all Tesla's over a
network so they all learn together it's
basically a hive mind of Tesla's it
almost seems like the perfect
combination of machine learning and
autonomy really cool stuff since there
are tens of thousands of humans training
the Tesla's and all the Tesla's learned
together that makes for a lot of
instructional data so all the test lists
should get very good at driving very
quickly
Elon says that the system should improve
every day by updating the driving
algorithm he goes on to say that Model S
owners could add approximately 1 million
miles of new data every day it's
interesting to note that just a few
weeks after the release Model S owners
on websites such as the Tesla Motors
Club are already describing how
autopilot is improving by itself here's
one example one guy tested autopilot on
roads with aggressive curves which Tesla
does not recommend but still as it turns
out the system is learning how to handle
sharp curves pretty fast the user with
the name Commerce science states that
the first time you use the car to take a
curve at full speed the car didn't stay
in the lane and issued the take control
immediately alert after a few times more
on this curve with firm pressure on the
steering wheel the car started to learn
to slow down first and then take the
corner and today the car has no issue
taking the curve it's definitely
learning I'll leave a link to the forum
in the description below so you can take
a look for yourself and what the
reactions are of the drivers whose cars
are starting to learn how to drive it's
pretty fascinating stuff and it's safe
to say what was once thought to be
science fiction is now a reality today
all right so let's go deeper how exactly
does this work according to Ilan there
are four pillars for autonomous driving
the first one is a long-distance radar
system that can see through virtually
anything this means
sand snow dust and other things that the
human eye might not be able to see
through the second enabling technology
is cameras with image recognition
software
the third ultrasonic sensors and the
fourth is satellite imagery with
real-time traffic when these systems are
all integrated you get a very robust
overall system that almost acts like a
digital extended safety cushion of
technology for your car so how is it
like to drive here's some insight
courtesy of CNET so we're going to try
and lane change here there's a car in my
blind spot right now so it won't do it
the car is gone let's see if it'll
change now
there we go as you can see we'll even
change lanes completely hands off right
now I'm gonna take my hands completely
off the wheel and my feet are off the
pedals as well and as you can see the
car is moving along on its own there's a
Volvo in front of us it's slowing down
and the cars recognize that there's a
blue car here on the dashboard which has
been improved of the new 7.0 software
and it basically is following the moves
of that car ahead of me so as it slows
down we will slow down and as it speeds
up we will - okay so before we wrap up
the video let's hear a bit from Elon
about the new technology this is him on
the subject of legal implications yes
but if it's on autopilot and the driver
says hey you know this was supposed to
change lanes for me and instead it hit
this barrier I want you know I want
Tesla to be responsible for this yeah I
think we're going to be quite clear with
customers that the responsibility
remains with the driver
we're not asserting that the car is
capable of driving in the absence of
driver oversight that will be the case
at some point the future like maybe five
or six years from now I think we'll be
able to treat achieved true autonomous
driving where you could literally get in
the car go to sleep and wake up your
destination I probably years ago I
thought it was more like ten years but
based on the rate of improvements that
I'm seeing and the progress we're making
I think we'll probably all do it in five
or six years and there's the standard
for fully autonomous driving is can be
much greater than for a person right
because it's just equivalent that
wouldn't be enough but in order to do
that you have to have fully redundant
systems everything is going to be
redundant so that any one system braking
does not result in an accident
and you also have to prove that out over
your millions of miles driving so I know
what a few of you are thinking what
about hacking it's a lot like a like a
cell phone or a laptop you know you
focus on making sure that they can't
they can't or that is very difficult for
there to be any kind of system-wide hack
so we put a lot of effort into that and
we have third parties try to attack it
and and in certain parts of the car at
the very fundamental level like the
drive unit controller or the steering
controller have an additional level of
security and you don't have to worry
about a Skynet scenario because Elon
himself is very wary of AI so you
yourself have invested in some AI
companies like deep mind and I carry us
yeah why I invested in those companies
to keep an eye on them I wanted to see
how artificial intelligence was
developing okay so what are the
conclusions to draw from this a lot of
people say Tesla is drastically
overvalued and will vanish with the
bursting of the new tech bubble although
it is true that we are in a tech bubble
I think Tesla is showing us something
that cannot be instantly measured
innovation they really are showing a
whole new way for an entire century-old
industry and I'd say even though it's
not easily measured that is very
valuable as mobile economist Robert
Shiller puts it quote technology has
made the biggest changes in our economy
we should start to take a look at GDP
and the productivity numbers differently
because they are not estimating or
capturing the impact of new technology
and quote and just to put that into
perspective Tesla as a whole is starting
to progress in their relevant markets
for example I just had a look at Tesla's
shareholder meeting and I was surprised
to find out that Tesla is now the number
one seller of high-end premium sedans in
North America not only this but for 2015
the Tesla Model S in Switzerland has
sold more than the Mercedes s-class BMW
6 Series and Audi a7 combined in
addition to this you can now travel
anywhere in the US using the
superchargers so all in all it's a great
job done by the Tesla team they've
repeatedly shown how the electric car is
the future and the latest efforts do
that by making the roads are safer place
and I think that's a good thing anyway
thanks for watching this video I hope
you got something out of it this has
been to gogo you've been watching cold
fusion if you want to see more stuff on
Tesla stick around for the next ten
seconds and follow the prompts on your
screen cheers guys I'll see you again
soon for the next video have a good one
cold fusion is drinking